[Music]
an unexpected discovery news submitted
by peace and love JK thousands of bones
were discovered in a vatican [ __ ] during
a search for a missing teenager this is
a crazy man thousands thousand in a Kris
yeah that's what this reminds me of that
[ __ ] da Vinci Code stuff man yeah
this is worse than that man oh yeah I
wasn't the bomb that's [ __ ] crazy
it's like the vinci code that turned
into like a conspiracy crazy thing they
also said they don't know if it's like
maybe ten or hundreds of bones that's
fragment or actual thousand but they're
doing tests but isn't a crypt where
you're supposed to put bones anyway yeah
so okay this started because there's
this girl who disappeared back in the
summer of 1983 named Emma Manuela
Orlandi and her parents like they worked
in the Vatican with Sara Vatican
employees and so they lived in the
Vatican City and so during that one
summer she was on her way home from a
music lesson in central Rome and that's
what she disappeared and so it's been
all these years that her family has
never given up and has tried looking for
her all these years
and so finally they got this anonymous
tip saying that maybe like check where
the angel is pointing and like just
really ominous clothes damn that's very
yes so trippy yeah and so what they were
referring to it's this this German
cemetery portion of the Vatican City and
they were saying that it might be
located in the tombs of Princess Sophie
von holo and Princess Charlotte Federico
sorry I tried of Mecklenburg so that's
where they checked those those tombs and
so this is the area and these are the
tombs and they didn't find nothing yeah
they did not find anything in fact it
was really strange because that guy's a
sorry tipper then they should have had
no but it's still such an epic way where
the angels pointing but it is leading to
a bigger mystery because there should
have been bones there
oh there's no
there's nothing there the bones weren't
there and so they were saying when they
were excavating or like you know just
looking through the the actual tomb
they're saying like chunks of that to
like the ceiling of the tomb is from
that era so back then is one they didn't
even put the bones in there so like who
knows what happened to the actual
denying so nobody nobody stole the bones
originally they think they just buried
empty yeah well that's the mystery right
now yeah they're saying like quite
possibly and just buried an empty tomb I
think they have a empty tomb oh I think
masks her murder or her deafening she
faked her own death yeah yeah it's just
a mystery we don't do these to princess
oh no okay so I'm referring to the two
princesses just to be clear right girl
yeah okay
so then like they're supposed to be
buried there but they're not there so
that's another man named forever she
faked her own death she was living up in
Versailles
yeah 1600 B Ella or Lundy this is a you
know like missing poster and this is
where they found those thousands of
bones that like it led them to like from
the tomb it led them to this particular
crypt with now they're reporting that
thousands and bones have been found they
don't know like Bart said like if it's a
few people or it's thousands of people
and they also don't know how recent
these bones are either like how recent
they date and so what a lot of
speculation they're saying in the media
it's like dude the Vatican City if these
bones are recent they got a lot of
explaining to do yeah like hopefully
there are a bunch of all bones of people
that are supposed to be there and the
crypts just got jumbled up
but the worst case scenario they could
just be a bunch of unsolved murders and
disappearing people that have been tied
to the Vatican and then that would be
[ __ ] crazy so now where was that
crypt in relation to the princess graves
happy yeah it was near it yeah they were
like let's just open everything here
well they were given more clues and it
was just one led to another and then
they started to I forgot what music
master yeah anonymous IP address whose
okhane these clues cause like the
Vatican's okaying them
they could bury in there I mean they
could dig in there yeah that's like for
me you win it when this story came up I
was like whoa because you don't ever
hear anything come out of the Vatican
City because it's just like it's pun
intended but it's just kind of like a
tomb like whatever happens it just kind
of stays there yes it's its own
sovereign nation it is with its own
military no its own interesting this was
they look like this with the Shakespeare
necklace the spears embackment is there
like the time of a team of Navy SEALs oh
well then they should dress like it they
want you to see them why do they look
like clowns man well that's their
ceremonial dress but when there were the
actual fatigues they have an armory full
of like ARS and stuff like that too but
they just have to wear like like like
they're working on medieval times it was
just interesting for me that this
anonymous tipper is giving people clues
and you're finding [ __ ] but know that
they're allowing it they're saying yeah
whoever's giving you these tips there's
some sort of sort of validity to it that
we and they are the ones testing the
bones all right I would if they knew
about this you know whole full bones why
wouldn't they be like no you can't we
can't go in here wouldn't they go in
first get rid of the bones maybe maybe
there's people within that group that
did this and then there's other people
that don't know and it's kind of like an
internal battle if there is a conspiracy
do you think we'll really know them yeah
probably not
because like TIFF said there's conflict
of interest because the Vatican City is
doing their own digging their own
testing oh well we're investigating
ourselves it's all good yeah right yeah
but they're the family so the brother of
his name is Pietro Orlandi he's saying
that you know the investigations into
the UH sororities are like it's a great
satisfaction and so he's very happy
right right bone structure yeah and so
he's also saying that it's important
that a private like source is also
looking into your bones because
verifying it yeah cuz the Vatican loves
to cover up things Vatican's like good
news all these bones are old bones so
it's crazy
and it's done in a private area where
the public can't even go and bury any
fat smile
that's a good point yeah I know it
because yeah they're saying that these
bones are discovered where they don't
have access I guess it's not accessible
to the public so it's whoever did this
is important about that criminals don't
just go where they're allowed to go if I
feel like there's no access they have to
follow the signs have you say no guns
allowed they don't bring a gun that's
exactly right
no it's like a private I mean it's it's
it's really guarded you old its submit
yeah it's really hard so it has to be an
inside job as what people were saying
like if this happened it's within the
Vatican and within the people yeah so
this sounds though the in Manila thing
like how is that relevant then because
it happened in 83 like why is this
person I mean our IP why is this person
so important that they had to go in and
be like Oh check here well why did the
clues come up now right that's a good
question something we've been thinking
about this girl I forgot I had these
clues or maybe they retired and they're
like finally I can tell all you know who
knows their NBA expired or the person
that actually did the crime died so they
feel oh you know I don't know like yeah
there might be a lot of they don't
everything but I think free your
question do I think it's because of the
fact that she was living in the Vatican
City and like it was a huge story back
when it first happened and it's been
something that's been constantly
investigated by the family so they seem
to have some sort of amount of power to
follow these clues because the Vatican
City agreed to it if the parents worked
at the Vatican they clearly have some
sort of I don't know access exactly yeah
I feel like here if we were like hey I
think there are some clues in this
casket people like [ __ ] off like they
got to open up some ancient asking
that's [ __ ] tight [ __ ] crazy
that's very nice releasing it's like
opening up George Washington's casket
and it'll cool with it I'm like I think
my brother's in there and they're like
okay we are very
I was asking like who approves is right
yes it is the Vatican themselves and
then they said in a statement they said
once again showing that there once again
showing its openness towards our Landy
family and that they are agreeing for
these investigations to take place even
if it was only based on an imam
anonymous report so they're trying to
say like you see how good we are
that's weird she's not the only missing
girl - there's several other girls that
were living or like in the Vatican and
they went missing
at around the same time well they
already got the boys at the altars oh
they don't want to kill the boys they
need the boys to stay alive it's the
girls oh no yeah but there's other other
girls that were missing and it's just
unsolved so I think it's also weird cuz
it's like they're a private you know
city and everything is all hidden that
if this happened like in any other
country it's like oh yeah it happens but
they're not the Vatican it just feels
like it should be extra protected that's
its own country they have their own
passports they allowed to set could they
have said no we're not opening up this
thing and everyone would just have to
drop it or were they trying to get ahead
of someone else coming in and doing the
oh they wanted to be the one you know I
don't know that might be there they make
the laws yeah it's crazy on something
that it's known force to be stilled all
religious entity of the world like
everyone knows the Vatican yeah talks
about that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] sexy to
all of us I'm going there in September
I'll let you know it's so secretive we
oh please do those checks about the
Vatican everything the the secrecy more
than Amsterdam the crypts the closed
doors the [ __ ] it is lost the [ __ ]
old library there man and they won't let
anyone in there and read [ __ ] yeah god
damn it what is it
Hank's got to go in there see and wasn't
that a sexy movie yeah oh yeah why does
it mean like Icefall all-powerful
military for what it's great I think
they got a lot of well well yeah they
have like from like hundreds and
hundreds of years ago and that's 182 and
it's not you fit if they do have a lot
of wealth and they're in the middle of
another country why can't they rely on
Italy's military to protect them why do
they need their own from Italy so it's
just crazy
I just think since they're known to all
of us as being so sexy they should show
a little more leg they should show they
should but that's why they're sexy Steve
because they won't yeah I saw a lot of
like whistleblowing and stuff from the
nuns that there was there's this
documentary the called the nuns no oh
but they came out and they were talking
about this evil as dude that was in the
Vatican and he was like getting them
that all be involved in orgies and drug
parties and all that yeah and then
there's also the why they're so
secretive yeah they just hiding [ __ ]
right so like that's the same thing it's
so it's so [ __ ] sexy Popey even even
though the the the american side of the
church where they would just send the
guys like if they get accused of
molestation they would just send them to
another church and you would just keep
doing it again and again and again who
started touching boys like who yeah like
who started touching boys a lot of guys
they don't Peter is the first Peter the
first the st. Peter st. Peter the first
does he ever Basilica yeah yeah yeah
they're like also like not to be like
you know a history buff I know a lot of
things in when they're building the
Great Wall of China they just like threw
all the bodies of people in what if this
was just like oh we built this crypt
sorry you're dead we're gonna bury you
in the crypt that you were building
that's true or like in code
the way you ended it with such
uncertainty I love questions
no I agree yeah it could be like when
they had the Black Plague like with the
catacombs or whatever like it's just a
bunch of people so they had to throw
people in there well it's a mixture of a
lot of things there's the plague there's
Wars there's all that you went in the
catacomb fight no that's the one thing I
think it's good to do either should I go
yes if you're going to Europe do
everything you should go to the Vatican
see you though it's blows your mind like
I got here because the donation plate I
mean I know how but it's like house how
was Bill Maher and like the 12 yards or
whatever yeah and they don't let you
take photos but I just we all take
photos there Nico how do they not let
you take forward they still gold from
indigenous people that's how it got
there no gold from indigenous people
that's how they got there
[Music]
[Music]